- L'accord céréalier entre déjàr
la paille. Trois mois après sa
signature, la Russie se retire,
en représailles de l'attaque dee
située en mer Noire.
Selon Moscou, les navires
attaqués participaient auxions .
Moscou accuse aussi les deux
pays d'être à l'origine des
fuites dont ont fait l'objet
les gazoducs Nord Stream, suiten
septembre dernier.
usations que nient Kiev
et le ministère de la Défense
britannique, qui acusent plutôt
l'attention de sa gestion
désastreuse, de son invasion en
Ukraine.
L'accord céréalier conclu eà ps
l'exportation de plus de
9 millions de tonnes der
la crise alimentaire mondiale
provoquéprovoquéprovoquéprovoqu.
Signé pour une durée de
120 jours, l'accord devaitnovem,
mais pouvait êtreautomatiquemen.
L'incertitude régnait toutefois
puisque depuis des semaines, le
se plaint de ne pouvoir vendre
sa production et ses engrais
raison des sanctions
occidentales.
la préservation de cet accord
vital, pour l'accès à
l'alimentation de millions de
personnes à travers le monde.
Radio-Canada, Montréal.